امام الحوادث المرعبه والضغط الشعبي كسرت
اداره بايدن الجمود قانون وصف بالاكثر
الصرامه منذ عقود عده نواب ديمقراطيون
وجمهوريون قانون جارلاند نسبه الى وزير
المدعي العام الامريكي الذي اعده وفق
اساسا بسيط اسلحه اقل
حوادث اقل البدايه من سهوله امتلاك السلاح
حسب قانون جارلاند يجبر يجبر الزبون على
اثبات الصحيفه السوابق العدليه بما فيها
العنف الاسري القانون لا يتضمن اجراءات
الردعيه فحسب فهو خصصا 13 مليار دولار
لدعم المتضررين دعم نفسي في المدارس
وتعويضا للمراكز التجاريه القريبه من
مواقع الجريمه ما جاء في القانون لقى
ترحيبا من الحزبين الا ان ماده جد لا تزال
تصنع الحدث وهي التي جاءت لتسهيل تطبيق
قانون العلم الاحمر او الرد فلاج قانون
العلم الاحمر الموجود في تسعه عشره ولايه
يسمح بمصادره الاسلحه من الاشخاص الذين
يظهرون سلوكا عنيفا او حتى اضطرابات نفسيه
مع حرمانهم من شراء اسلحه جديده
[موسيقى]
من هي خطوه كبيره نحو الامام لكنها غير
كافيه وهكذا وصفها بايضا خاصه وان تجار
السلاح في المقابل قطعوا خطوات اكبر
للالتفاف على القوانين دعونا نلقي نظره
على قطعه سلاح عاديه القوانين تفرض على
المصنع نحت رقم تسلسلي على كل سلاح وهو
امر يسمح للسلطات بتتبع السلاح ومعرفه
المنتج والمالك ايضا الا انها تشار السلاح
ابتدعوا طرقا جديده للتحايل وذلك ببيع قطع
منفصله من السلاح ليتمكن الزبائن بعدها من
تركيبها في البيت وبوسائل بسيطه وهو ما
يجعل السلاح شبحيا وخارج الرقابه شركات
اخرى لجات لحيله اخرى الطباعه الثلاثيه
الابعاد تعرض تعرض مواقع الشركات تصميم
قطع الغيار قبل تقتني تجار صغار الطباعه
طابعات ثلاثيه الابعاد من اجل صناعتها
اللغه الارقام تظهر تعقيد الامر ففي 2016
صادرت امريكا 1700 قطعه سلاح شبحيه لكن
هذه الارقام تضاعفت 12 مره عام 2021 يعني
ان الاسلحه زادت وبكميات ضخمه لكن ماذا
بعد الحل الوحيد يكمن في الزام المصنعين
بنحت الرقم التسلسلي على كل قطعه غيار لكن
هذا قانون لم يحن وقته بعد
[موسيقى]